keshia knight pulliam legal drama just
took a disturbing turn the former child
star is accusing her estranged husband
and Hardwell of engaging in behavior
that would cause her to have a
miscarriage this is his daughter Keisha
announced in july she's expecting her
first child with Ed she's now accusing
him of plotting to harm and obstruct her
pregnancy me in court docs filed last
week The Cosby Show actress claimed that
Hartwell was mentally and emotionally
abusive throughout their relationship in
heart Wells legal response filed
Wednesday he denies the actress abuse
claims calling them despicable the
former NFL star filed for divorce from
Keyshia just days after she revealed she
was pregnant when et sat down with
Keyshia she got emotional about the
pair's relationship this is a baby in
the middle of this and regardless if we
don't want to be married that's fine
because we agree on that we neither one
of us want to be married a little bit I
have no desire to continue to be married
to him but this baby is what's important
you